[Music]
more than two billion kobe 19 vaccines
administered worldwide halfway
vaccinated
as millions get vaccinated many reunions
are happening around the country it's
been a very long time and so much life
has happened
you're gonna have the best night you've
had for a very long time we've all been
through something collectively it's been
such a difficult time and it's even
harder pretending like everything's
normal when it's not
700 000 people quit retail jobs as the
so-called great resignation picked up
speed they just didn't care about me
anymore there is not a shortage of jobs
there is a shortage of decent jobs the
shortage of products has extended to
just about everything big shortage of
lumber shortage of snowblowers and a
shortage of microchips look at those
bones can you not
please
the growing backlog in the global supply
chain a giant container ship wedged from
bank to bank
guys
get rich off game stop while bankrupting
a bunch of hedge funds it's been a fun
ride with gamestop a few things i am not
i'm not a cat it just shows how much
power the rich people have what is an
nft sold for nearly 70 million
literally sending dogecoin to the moon
anyone with enough money can become an
astronaut
looking down
[Applause]
we need some of the world's greatest
brains fixed on trying to repair this
planet not trying to find the next place
to go and live
the report is very clear we expect to
see new extremes that are unprecedented
in magnitude timing or in regions that
have never encountered those types of
extremes the most affected people in the
most affected areas still remain unheard
myanmar has been under political chaos
since hunter-led military coup asked the
elected government farmers in india are
marking a year since they began the
biggest protest in the country's modern
history the deadly conflict between
israeli forces and palestinians
continues
the government of ethiopia has been
locked in a year-long war with the
degree people's liberation from sudden
wave of thousands of migrants has
sparked a humanitarian crisis at the u.s
mexico border
how can you do that to human being to
other human beings it's time for
american troops to come home
afghanistan
it's a very very crazy situation right
now
they broke the glass in the united
states capital and now they are climbing
through the window the world
[Music]
these people coordinated on open parts
of the internet on instagram on facebook
these platforms are not merely mirroring
humanity they're making all of us
our worst selves i am proud to announce
that starting today our company is now
meta people really underestimate the
power of misinformation people who've
had these shots and now they're
magnetized
[Music]
this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
[Music]
people haven't related to it you see the
figures the daily figures
and their nameless faces
[Music]
india is being ravaged by a second wave
covert 19 is threatening to overwhelm
the country's health systems we don't
have anything and patients are dying a
person cannot live here in delhi a
person cannot even die peacefully in
delhi vaccine inequality cannot be
allowed to continue omicron is spreading
at a rate we have not seen with any
previous variant the more this virus
spreads the more likely it is for a very
dangerous variant to emerge we're in
this together and the only way we're
going to conquer this virus is by
working together
[Music]
they've agreed to share the gold medal
just because you're a female it doesn't
mean you can't accomplish the biggest of
goals the philippines first ever olympic
gold medal put your mental health first
it doesn't matter if you're on the
biggest stage that's more important than
any other medal you could win
there's so many people who are afraid to
voice that they need help to truly
choose to love is heroic chile's
congress has passed a bill allowing
same-sex couples to marry britney spears
is free
harlan any of these police ever go to
prison we the jury find the defendant
guilty
i'm sorry
with the asian american community enough
is enough we're just we're just fed up
what i really hope that this movie can
do is show asian kids that it's okay to
take up space where they are because
they belong i know where i'm headed in
life i know what my future is going to
look like when something says taylor's
version that means i own it rock and
roll never dies there are people who
don't believe that women can be better
presidents and we are here to show them
taking its first steps in pursuit of
cosmological discovery
we did not feel prepared to be the heirs
of such a terrifying hour but within it
we found the power to author a new
chapter to offer hope and laughter to
ourselves so
while once we asked how could we
possibly prevail over catastrophe
now
we assert
how could catastrophe possibly prevail
over us
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you